[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt es ein richtiges rezept und
zwar mache ich diese frühlingshaften
cupcakes und die cupcakes sind dekoriert
mit einer buttercreme ich habe da eine
trinkwasser krim gemacht mit vanille
also richtig lecker und unten da habe
ich noch johannes benz zeigt das macht
das ganze richtig saftig und die sind
wirklich wunderschön und die
spritztechnik die super einfach ich habe
dafür einfach ne spritztour verwendet
und die sind echt auch sehr schnell
hergestellt vor allem wenn ihr mal was
verschenken wollt oder irgendwo
eingeladen zeit und habt vielleicht
keine lust was zu kaufen
dann könnt ihr was selbst gemachtes
schenken finde ich echt schön ich zeige
euch jetzt erstmal die zutaten für den
muffins trägt damit den muffins
pietätlos für den teig brauche ich 150
gramm zucker eine prise salz 190 gramm
mehl einen halben teelöffel backpulver
und ein viertel teelöffel natron zweier
200 milliliter buttermilch 150 gramm
flüssige butter etwas vanille extrakt
den abrieb von einer zitrone dies
unbehandelt und 60 von johannisbeeren
die muffins sinne super schnell
hergestellt denn ihr verrückt einfach
die trockenen zutaten in der schüssel
und dann kommen die flüssigen zutaten
dazu
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt noch der abrieb der
zitrone mit rein
und wer möchte kann auch ein spritzer
zitronensaft dazugeben
jetzt kommen hier noch die
johannisbeeren rein da können sie
entweder frisch oder tiefgefroren eben
ganz egal
ganz kurz einrühren und dann könnt ihr
den teig schon in die muffin vom
einfüllen
[Musik]
und während die machen setzt im ofen
backen kann ich mich schon mal um die
creme kümmern ich werde jetzt gleich
eines wissen rang buttercreme machen
da schaut er einfach in meinen
grundrezepte nach
wir sind jetzt die fertigen muffins sie
sind auch bereits abgekühlt
und hier habe ich meine swissmetro creme
de ist wirklich super lecker und jetzt
habe ich hier noch neutral und würfe sie
oder verfeinertes sie mit etwas vanille
extrakt ihr könnt hier aber auch zum
beispiel empört einrühren oder auch eine
marmelade und ihr könnt ihr mit der
marmelade oder mit dem potpourri was ihr
eingekocht habt die creme auch ganz
einfach selber färben das eine schälchen
habe ich jetzt ein mit etwas
lebensmittelfarbe passte dann nehme ich
jetzt etwas blau und das andere bleibt
schön hell
[Musik]
und hier habe ich jetzt die helle
buttercreme und diese jetzt nicht ganz
schneeweiß und wenn man sie komplett
schneeweiß haben möchte kann man zum
beispiel ein bisschen einzige weitere
nehmen das ist auch eine
lebensmittelfarbe in weiß und das macht
die creme ein bisschen heller
[Applaus]
und jetzt kommen die eigentliche clou
ich habe zwei farben und verwende jetzt
zum spritzen hier diese tolle das ist
eine tulpe hülle und damit ich jetzt die
zweifarben in dem spritzbeutel gut rein
bekomme außen dunkel innen hell nehme
ich jetzt hier frischhaltefolie da kommt
jetzt blau drauf also das was man außen
haben möchte
[Musik]
und hier innen kommt jetzt die hände
creme rein aber nur in die mitte jetzt
nehmt ihr die frischhaltefolie schneidet
jeden teil weg und können dann auf
rollen
und jetzt nehme ich den richtigen
spritzbeutel da kommt die schülerin und
fordern kann ich die spitze wegschneiden
und bei der farben rolle hier vorne
die spitze wegschneiden und dann in den
spritzbeutel rein
jetzt nimmt dir am besten zum üben
zuerst mal einen teller und da könnte
jetzt so viel raus drücken müsst euch
die farbe gefällt und ich mache die
tülle immer ganz sauber und die creme
kam er später wieder weiter verwenden
jetzt unten ansetzen
fuchs deswegen müssen unten ansetzen und
hoch zehn
so gefallen mit den blüten jetzt ganz
gut und jetzt können sie auf die
cupcakes gespritzt werden
[Musik]
und so bin ich jetzt hier blau weiß
gemacht habe kann man natürlich auch
ganz viele farbkombinationen machen
wichtig ist nur wenn man den strizz
beutel hält wird die creme richtig warm
das heißt nicht zu lange in der hand
halten und falls die creme doch mal zu
weich wird ihr merkt es einfach da kann
man nicht mehr so gut spritzen aber auch
kurz in den kühlschrank legen und damit
er weiter offen
[Musik]
die capex in soweit fertig jetzt will
natürlich noch die blätter dafür habe
ich die mutter können grün eingefärbt
und habe hier vorne so eine kleine teile
dran
sie hat so richtig lustige zacken und
damit lassen sich blätter am besten
spritzen dafür einfach kurz ansätzen
spritzen und schnell exil
[Musik]
es ist so gefallen mir die cupcakes
richtig gut vor allem die farben sind
sehr farbenfroh und wichtig ist dass wir
natürlich im kühlschrank gelagert werden
dann sind sie auch beim transport
wirklich sicher weil die mutter fest
wird aber vor dem verzehr empfehle ich
euch dass ihr sie eine halbe stunde
vorher aus dem kühlschrank holt so
schmeckt die buttercreme am besten
und wer möchte kann sie noch toppen mit
diesen schmetterlingen die sind echt
super schön und die könnt ihr hier das
ss papier kurz vor dem verzehr einfach
raus lösen dann einmal knicken und zum
beispiel gedrosselten
dann hab da noch ein bisschen
frühlingsgefühle auf den cupcakes also
falls ihr die nach machen möchtet dann
findet ihr das rezept auch sally smith
blog.de ich freue mich schon auf eure
türken cupcakes ich werde jetzt ein paar
meiner mama schenken und dann vielleicht
der nachbarschaft noch ein bisschen die
freuen sich auf jeden fall über blumen
ihr wisst ja dann klappt's auch mit dem
nachbarn und ja ich freue mich auf eure
fotos was wollte ich noch sagen woran
ist leider gerade nicht da daher kann er
nicht probieren aber sie schmecken sehr
sehr gut also bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
und so wie ich jetzt hier blau und weiß
gemacht habe kann ich natürlich auch
ganz viele andere farbkombinationen
machen
ich übergebe dir das wort jagd rot rot
und gelb und pink und lila alles klar
rot gelb pink lila machen